une tranquille rue résidentielle sur le
chemin de de Riv à saintsusanne la rue
George Fourcat serpente entre les cases
qui se blottissent au fond de leur cours
coloré elle vit au rythme des collég et
raisonne de champ d'oiseaux est s'en
souvenir de George
Fourcade est-ce que vous savez qui était
George Fourcade non c'était un musicien
non avec un violon c'est pas un écrivain
il a eu le premier prix quelle année là
je peux pas vous dire je ne sais plus
pour petit fleur fané ptit fleur fané
ptit fleur séché pourquoi c'est lu écrit
cette chanson c'est
lu moin toujours c'est des chansons
c'est des vieux trucs
ça
né à Saint-Denis en juillet 1884 dans
une famille de rédacteurs George Fourcat
choisit trèsôt la musique et les
chansons il faut dire qu'il vou une
véritable vénération à sa grand-mère
Gabrielle Laclé musicienne renommée avec
son ami Jul fossi il écrit des tubes qui
resteront dans l'histoire mon mari
pêcheurp an
is prendrai plus tard les fameux jokaris
on lui doit aussi la célèbre petite
fleur aimée née en 1930 de quelques
vieux pétales et d'une mèche de cheveux
au fond d'un coffret avec lesquel il dut
composer une chanson pour rentrer dans
la Société des auteurs et compositeurs
de
musique un morceau aujourd'hui encore
sur toutes les lèvres et qui ne fannera
jamais George Fourcade excelle aussi
dans le théâtre ses histoires la case au
créol fleur seront réédité 10 fois entre
1928 et
1939 la musique est
caprin il signe également affair coco le
coq Auguste et reçoit de prix de
l'académie de la Réunion pour mondouddou
et pour le cœur créole portraitiste de
talent il signe son savoureux portrait
de petit George par lui-même et il peut
aussi se transformer en moraliste en
pastichant le corbeau et le renard en
Papang et le chat
Maron mais sa plume c'est un jour envolé
c'était le 29 décembre